More perfect is supported by zip recruiter.
Looking for your next great hire zip recruiter offers simple tools and powerful
matching technology to help you find qualified candidates fast.
It's the smartest way to hire.
Try It for free at ziprecruiter.com/more perfect.
That's ziprecruiter.com/more perfect
[inaudible] to support it. W in YC Studios,
leadership support from workers [inaudible] by the Joyce Foundation.
Our story today starts a couple of years back on February 26 2014 Washington DC
[inaudible]
you know we got up very early that morning. This is February, I believe so.
It was pretty cold and I'll tell you,
we were sitting there and I'm sort of the cavernous, you know,
empty a metro station rehearsing Chi says he and his friend Ryan Clayton went
through what they were about to do over and over and over.
It was very helpful to just sort of go through it and go through and go through
it.
[inaudible]
Jane comes, they hop on the train ticket, a couple of stops,
get out, walk a couple blocks, cross a few streets,
and then walk up the marble steps to the Supreme Court.
And then we have to wait in line, get through security.
Um, and you're trying, you know,
you're trying to just be cool once they're inside,
they pretend not to know each other. And then, uh, you know,
you get brought into the chamber.
My first time ever being inside, they take their seats in the spectator section,
look around and it's such a grand kind of intimidating space.
[inaudible]
there are these red velvet curtains at the back and if you look up marble
carvings on the, uh, the walls and the ceiling
and on the north and south walls,
there are these huge portraits of great lawmakers through history.
Moses Hammurabi, John Marshall, Muhammad.
So I was just taking all of that in feeling, feeling the butterflies,
and I had a sense that, uh, it was very much doable.
And then it's just waiting. Eventually the court Marshall comes out,
says a few words about how it works when you're in there.
And not to speak and so on. And then finally the nine justices enter the room,
almost like priests on a cloud,
their robes sort of whispering around them at that point tried to meditate son,
just be smart and stay cool.
And then chief justice John Roberts speaks your argument first this morning in
case 12 1184 octane fitness versus icon health and fitness incorporated.
He was a patent case case itself.
Isn't that important MR chief justice and may it please the court because after
the lawyers make their arguments,
there are no further questions your honor or is your to affirm the cases
submitted then thank you counsel. I saw Ryan make his motion and I was just
that point just sort of like the practice in the sense of readiness and you know
a little bit of sort of a rock and roll. Han Solo Spirit, you know,
to just say like it's, it's game time. We've just got to do this thing.
And I stood and said,
I arrived on behalf of the vast majority of the American people who believe that
money is not me
and that our democracy should not be for sale,
would not be for sale, the highest bidder [inaudible]
I saw the security coming towards me from the left and like people getting up
and then sort of crashing through the chairs, attacking me from behind
the bear, hug me and then pulled me back through those people.
[inaudible]
okay. Newkirk was arrested. He spent the night in jail,
later pled guilty to three misdemeanor charges, but no one had noticed Ryan.
No one had noticed that they were together,
that Ryan had secretly videotaped the entire episode.
So when the day's session was over and Ryan went home and posted the video onto
youtube, the story just went crazy. Outburst,
a protest protestor interrupting the cord on Wednesday protest or objecting to
the role of money in politics because almost no outsider had ever gotten a
camera into the quarter. This isn't supposed to happen.
It's not supposed to happen. Tony, obviously a cameras are bad from the courts.
Cameras have never been allowed inside the nation's highest court. In second,
they'll go the gall of someone to walk into that esteemed chamber and do that to
those esteemed justices. And by the way,
not just once. You'll get an argument first this morning in case Boutine footie.
You know the Supreme Court action that we did in February,
2014 was the first but not the last. Thank you, MR chief justice.
Here's the fifth anniversary of citizens United and there were seven people who
did [inaudible]
[inaudible].
This is from January 21st, 2015 security again,
rounds up. The protesters are second order of business.
Do you have any [inaudible]
chief justice Roberts tries to laugh it off. Oh, please.
In the same recording,
you can sort of hear justice Ginsburg trying to figure out like how many,
how many protesters are in the room. We have another one,
a couple over there too.
He's [inaudible].
Over the next year or so, we did more actions. Next one,
April 1st, 2050
dean,
see if there's another
justices, Scalia and Thomas murmuring to each other.
Didn't think the bankruptcy cases would attract such attention. Oh, please.
You can hear Justice Thomas say, I think that's the same dude as the last
[inaudible]
kind of hard to hear over the yelling.
But you can sorta hear Justice Scalia lean over to Thomas and say,
we should throw these people in jail. Basically.
Anyone else interested in talking?
We'll be admonished that it's within the authority of this court to punish such
disturbances by criminal contempt.
We moved. Sorry.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] do it.
So here's why we started the story this way over and over again.
The protestors call out one case.
It's one of the most controversial cases in American history.
It was decided on January 21st, 2010 and two a good chunk of America.
That was the day that corporations to control of American [inaudible]
democracy.
[inaudible]
it is the dark ages. It is our dreads. Scott
[inaudible],
I would suggest a revolution, but a revolution against the corporations,
the corporations that make all the guns and the bullets
get rid of citizens. Yeah,
no, I did. And it's partnership affects on our own.
That's one of the worst supreme court decisions.
It's misguided naive on courageous decision of the United States Supreme Court,
I think in the 21st century.
So this season more perfect.
We're rethinking a lot of the most hated Supreme Court decisions.
And this one citizens United is definitely right.
She overturned
it is widely loathed across the political spectrum.
We got curious why, why is it hated so much?
What exactly is this case? Why was it decided the way it was decided?
And it turns out that that last question gives you a unique window into not just
how the supreme court works, but inside the mind
of arguably the most powerful man in America.
The honorable, the chief justice,
and the associate justices of the Supreme Court of the United States.
Oh, Yay. Oh Yay.
Well yeah, having business before the honorable,
the Supreme Court of the United States, red monies to draw in Aaron
[inaudible], who's now
God's Fabian faith in this honorable card
[inaudible].
Okay, so the
story of citizens United begins with a letter
landmark film from the core doors. There's power ChiroThin,
small town America.
Impressive grab ass. And I have more.
Some people call you the elite. I call you.
My name is summer 2004 commercials for it.
Fahrenheit nine 11 are all over the place.
It's the true story that will make you a candidate.
You've seen the documentary, you know,
it's very critical of then president George W.
Bush for leading America into war based on false intelligence and the
commercials.
When you looked at them,
they came across as highly political and highly effective, um,
ads.
This is Michael Bose. He is one of the three Bs.
Did the story know at the time that he was seeing these ads to his eye?
They came across as, especially political because at the time as president,
I'll set a few clear national priorities for America. Over the past three years,
Americans have faced many serious challenges. That summer George W.
Bush was in a tight race with the Democratic nominee. John Kerry.
In which direction would John Kerry lead and actual political ads.
George Bush is misleading America. We're running wall to wall.
John Kerry has repeatedly opposed weapon's vital to winning the war on terror.
Yeah, it's going to true. I mean ads for Fahrenheit nine 11
I call upon all nations to do everything they can.
I mean they did kind of, it kind of blended, right? Yeah.
[inaudible]
ah, I saw the impact of Fahrenheit nine 11 and late July.
This is David Bossie be number two in an interview that he gave to Cspan.
I,
I decided over the couple of weeks that a Fahrenheit was out there that it just
was having a lot bigger impact than even I wanted to admit
to this day. Uh,
Fahrenheit nine 11 is the top grossing documentary of all time in that summer of
2004 when the film was out, Bose and Bossy were like, ah,
George Bushes down on the polls. Maybe this film has something to do with it.
And so they decided
we ought to produce a documentary film that essentially counters Fahrenheit nine
the we that he's talking about is the conservative nonprofit that he and bossy
run called surprise, surprise citizens United,
David Bossie B two is the chairman and president of citizens United,
Michael Bose B one
I'm the executive vice president and the general counsel.
And just for context,
the guy who started citizens United is behind one of the most devastating
political ads of all time, Bush and do caucus on crime.
Bush supports the death penalty for first degree murderers.
New conquers not only opposers the death penalty,
he allowed first degree murderers to have weekend passes from prison.
The Willie Horton ad in 1988 that pretty much tanked. Michael Dukakis,
his presidential campaign.
Anyhow,
after Bose and bossy saw how successful Fahrenheit nine 11 was and more
importantly, how much precious air time the movies ads were getting.
They thought,
let's do this.
We went out and we found the best filmmakers in Hollywood that could do this.
Let's make a movie. We produced it.
It was called Celsius 41 11 the temperature at which the brain begins to die,
you know, liberal brains cities by Michael Moore's movie,
and then we wanted to run television ads to promote that [inaudible].
We ran into that problem,
a big fat problem.
[inaudible]
f e c
[inaudible],
the Federal Election Commission, which by the way was created in 1974
sure.
After Watergate where basically people have got to know whether or not they're
presidents of crop. You had campaign money. Oh I, I'm not a crook.
[inaudible]
funding a crime. Okay.
So the FEC came about post Watergate to basically regulate money and elections
to keep money from corrupting politics.
And
when Bose and Bossy were like, we want to run these ads, the FEC was like,
look, your ads do not qualify.
Can't do it. Cause even though you are a nonprofit,
you cannot use your corporate piggy bank, I. E.
Your Treasury to put ads on the air cause you remember that law that we have?
Yeah.
John McCain won his battle for campaign finance reform.
The 2002 bipartisan campaign before Mag also known as McCain Feingold restricts
the use of corporate money directly for or against candidates.
I remember that law FEC said if you ran ads you would be violating that law too.
Which Bossy B two was like, Hey, wait a minute. What about Michael Moore?
This guy is running TV commercials,
which in my opinion we're a lot better than John Kerry's commercials trying to
make George Bush look bad. Why the F
[inaudible]
does he get to run ads and we don't. The his response was like,
he's media.
He can run ads on TV because he gets a media exemption. You,
you're not media, y'all are corporate.
So at that point in time we decided that we would get in the documentary
filmmaking business,
so citizens, United producers,
broken promises in the United Nations at 61
of the things it's very difficult for outsiders to understand about the UN is
how we all prepared and untrained. Most of its staff are
2006 border war, the battle over illegal immigration.
We never really crossed the border. The border cross ties that same year,
the Acru has been more concerned about protecting pedophiles than protected.
If a shoulder they produce ACL
you at war with America.
And by 2008 we had a substantial history of making documentary films that we had
made over that period of times. Several had won awards.
Anyhow,
fast forward to January of 2008 the United States is heading into another
presidential election and the two candidates on the democratic side.
I'm Hillary Clinton and I approve this message.
I'm Barack Obama and I approve this message.
Of course, Hillary Clinton and Barack Obama and citizens United productions.
That's their nonprofit movie production wing made a new film,
vindictive Venal sneaky ideological intolerant.
Why are is a good one? Super Subtle. It's called Hillary
the moon.
She is steeped in controversy steeped in sleaze.
And guess what?
We faced the same obstacle that we faced in 2004
the FTC basically told Bose and Bossy, you can make the movie.
You just can't let anyone know it exists.
I was forbidden to advertise. Again, this was because of McCain. Fine.
Gold advertisements paid for with corporate money couldn't go on TV or on the
radio 30 to 60 days before an election or primary.
People don't understand how McCain-Feingold criminalized political speech.
My lawyers told me I would be indicted and put in prison for five years per
count. Meaning every time they found a violation I could be put in prison.
And so, so we decided to not let the FEC,
the federal election commission come for us. We actually sued them. We sue.
Well, we sue. This is Jim. Bob B3.
He is in Indiana based campaign finance lawyer.
Mr [inaudible]. Thank you MR chief justice and may it please the court. Okay.
So the three B's take their Hillary, the movie case to Federal Court.
Um, we lost,
they lost, they appeal directly to the Supreme Court.
And Voila.
We'll hear argument today in case zero eight two oh five citizens United versus
the Federal Election Commission. Mr. Olsen, right. So we're,
we're in the courtroom now, right?
I'm just a patient in the political process.
Say A, I remember the urine unsurprising argument.
This is journalist and author Marshall Coil.
She says you had the lawyer for the BS.
Ted Olsen taking a very strong position, basically saying, look,
by not allowing us to run our ads for Hillary, the movie,
it's wrong and you're violating our first amendment rights
in the case that you consider today,
it is a felony for a small nonprofit corporation to offer interested viewers.
A 90 minute political documentary. Ooh, one more time.
The 90 minute documentary again, this 90 minute documentary. Yeah.
90 documentary, a 90 minute documentary documentary.
90 minute movie. The 90 minute documentary in 90 minutes.
[inaudible] this 90 minute documentary in 90 minute documentary in 90 minute
documentary about a candidate for the nation's highest office.
Just 90 minute documentary in 90 minute documentary.
Okay. So you know how like when you hear a certain word over and over and over,
it just turns into Mush at 90 minute documentary. Indeed, this documentary,
I mean it happens all the time when you listen to supreme court oral arguments
documentary, but particularly in this case, uh, in his opening statement,
Ted Olson said that word documentary so many times.
It just started to sound so weird.
But the point he was trying to make by saying it again and again and again,
the documentary is,
is it citizens United was making a documentary that discussions things that are
important to the public. They were not quote, electioneering, electioneering,
electioneering, electioneering electioneering. Okay, election here.
That's another a word you hear over and over again. You're just like, wow,
what a weird word. But what it means is like campaign advocacy,
and there are certain words, eight of them actually words and phrases like,
vote for elect support,
cast your ballot for vote against defeat.
Reject those words.
Or the functional equivalent of those words according to the court,
suddenly make something advocacy electioneering and therefore regulated.
But citizens United said, look, this is a movie about Hillary Clinton. You know,
we don't save, vote or don't vote for her. And you know,
it still may be shown in theaters sold on DVDs.
We're trying to disseminate the movie to an independent buyer who will then
offer it, say through HBO, which is make a movie. Indeed.
This documentary, yes,
is the very definition of robust on inhibited debate about a subject of intense
political interest that the first amendment is there to guarantee
Mr. Olsen if the film were, but then liberal justice is like a David Souter.
We're like, come on,
see, I mean, I've got the government's brief over and it open up.
Pages 18 and 19 was the quotations. Uh,
she lie about anything. She's deceitful, she's ruthless, cunning, dishonest,
uh, do anything for power. I will speak dishonestly, uh, reckless.
That congenital liar's solely lacking in qualifications,
not qualified as commander in chief.
I mean this sounds to me like campaign advocacy. Electioneering this is eight,
don't vote for Jones.
This is a long discussion of the record qualifications,
history and conduct of someone who was in the political arena.
So they go back and forth for a while.
What could was citizens United just making an elaborate campaign ad but dressing
an episode doc or was it actually a dog? But what is the, between the
ten second commercial and say the 90 minute infomercial? Like how can you tell?
Is it about length? Is it about who's doing the speaking blah, blah, blah.
As Marcia Coil said, this part of the argument is unsurprising.
Thank you council.
Then Mr. Stewart, uh,
the government I got out of strategic justice and may it please the court,
and this is where things really start turning right. So the government's lawyer,
Malcolm Stewart
gets up there and he says, these ads for this movie and this movie
are clearly electioneering come on.
A court should find that an ad is the functional equivalent of express advocacy
only if the ad is susceptible of no reasonable interpretation other than it's an
appeal to vote for or against a specific candidate.
That's a very complicated way of saying if you watched the damn movie it,
you just can tell it looks like an ad. It smells like an ad. It's an ad.
It's certainly been a recurring phenomenon in the past that candidates would
air, for instance, 30 minute infomercial. So that's all fine and good.
But then Walmart airs an advertisement that says we have candidate action
figures for sale. Come buy them.
That counts as an electionary in communication if it's aired in the right place
at the right time, that would be covered. Now,
when Chief Justice Roberts and also Alito,
you think that the constitution required congress to draw the line where it did
testing Malcolm Stewart probing how far the government can go.
What's your answer to Mr Olson's?
Like if the government is allowed to say like that thing you're doing as an ad,
therefore it should be taken off the air at certain times or where's the limit
to that? Like what if the ad,
as the government defines it is in a DVD or a book,
can it then just yank those away too?
But the constitution permit the restriction of all of those as well.
I think the constant constitution would have permitted congress to apply the
electioneering communication restrictions to the extent that there are
otherwise. Any here where
you almost hear the conservative justice as being like, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, whoa,
Whoa, whoa. Did he just say, did he just say what I think he just said?
Did you say that? That's pretty incredible. You think that if, if, uh,
a book was published,
a campaign biography that was the functional equivalent of express advocacy,
a that could be banned? I'm not saying it could be banned.
I'm saying that Congress could prohibit the use of corporate treasury funds and
could require a quarter. If it has to get one name,
one use of the candidate's name, it would be covered. Correct.
If that's, if it's a 500 page book and at the end it says,
and so vote for x, the government could ban that.
Well,
if it says for exit would be express advocacy and it would be covered by the
preexisting federal election campaign act provision now comes to it tries to
wriggle out of this trap. If it's a book and it is,
he brings in some stuff about that first amendment about media protections,
media corporations,
the institutional press would have a greater first amendment right.
That that pop question is obviously not presented that the other two things that
we're an advocacy organization that had a book,
but Justice Kennedy pins it back down.
Your position is that under the constitution, uh,
the advertising for this book or the sale for the book itself could be
prohibited within the 60, 30 day period.
If the book contained the functional equivalent of express advocacy,
what happens is they eventually get him to say
if it's a block and at the end it says,
vote for X. Yes.
Our position would be that the corporation could be required to use PAC funds
rather than general treasury. And if they didn't, you could ban it.
If they didn't, we could prohibit the publication of the book.
You mean the government can ban books?
[inaudible]
being a, you know, in the courtroom and hearing that answer, well,
it was stunned silence.
That's Jim, Bob B3, v I. D. A
that anything the government could do,
could amount to banning a book, you know,
sent a shockwave through the courtroom and that's Jeffrey Toobin from the New
Yorker. He was also in the audience that day.
This deep dark kind of secret was now exposed to the,
to the light of day to the public that they really were in the book banning book
burning business.
The question of the book underlines how difficult it is when the government gets
into regulating a political speech.
Malcolm Stewart kept protesting like, no, no, no, no, no, you're not.
You're misunderstanding.
I'm not saying it could be bad.
I'm saying the congress could prohibit the use of corporate treasury.
Well, this is not about banning political speech.
It's about regulating the money used to make that speech because if we don't
sometimes do that, some voices will be way too loud. Okay. That's the F,
you know?
That's a fine distinction in the minds of the average person and it's a
distinction she says. It just got lost that day
because Congress said,
if we accept your constitutional argument where establishing a precedent that
you yourself say would extend to banding the book,
assuming a particular person pays for it.
I think the court has already hilled in both in Austin and in McConnell,
but congress
coming up,
we go behind the scenes into the minds actually if the justices as they
deliberate backstage about what to do next and things get kind of weird.
Yeah,
more perfect is supported by zip recruiter.
The smartest way to hire quality talent fast. With ZipRecruiter,
you can post your job to 100 plus job boards with just one click.
Then let ZipRecruiter's powerful technology match your job to the right
candidates and use their simple dashboard to find your perfect hire. In fact,
80% of employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate through the
site within one day.
Try It for free at ziprecruiter.com/more perfect. That zip
recruiter.com/more perfect.
He's from Washington from snap, snap,
duck live walks Nashville Wyman theater firing mark 16 and I'm bringing the best
of what goes in the world last Friday.
Laugh some more amazing night out and yes, she's coming.
The funniest woman in the world, Jen Kober.
I do my hung in the lady forest. Jen POBA rocks a brand new story.
Get tickets it snap judgment. That'll watch it.
I've never gotten applause for it before. If you guys could call my mom,
that'd be awesome. She's still pissed
in the supreme court today. A debate about the movies.
Short of producers have a withering 90 minute movie critique of Hillary Clinton
argued that part of the McCain Feingold campaign finance law is
unconstitutional.
All right, so after oral arguments wrapped up,
the justices retreated to what is perhaps the most secretive place in the known
universe and the most private and perhaps important place inside the supreme
court for at least inside the court justices and only then meet together around
a table and the justices conference room.
They discuss the cases heard at oral argument and begin the process of reaching
a decision of the court. This is a place where cameras will never go.
No one can enter the room except for some reasons cspan. Once we returned.
Now two Seaspans feature documentary, the Supreme Court,
once upon a time Seaspan,
those bastards were able to get into this room and film the table and the chair.
That's terrific. No, wait a minute. I'm actually quite jealous because they did.
They didn't let us do that.
They didn't let us see the special room or speak to the justices.
So Seaspan yeah, they have some kind of deal with the devil. Anyhow,
the point is we don't know what happened in that room on that day,
but we can piece together a couple of things. We can imagine the rest.
I mean we know that they went
in, Clarence Thomas put on some tunes. RBG was like, wow,
that book thing I need to drink. Actually,
we don't know that either of those two things happen,
but it makes sense to me that Clarence Thomas would like the doobies.
That just feels right,
but what do know is that the justice sat down in the usual order. They said,
we sit at the conference table in the same places every day.
Chief Justice Roberts gets things gone with some discussion.
I initiate the discussion because he always does for an argued case. I'll say,
this case is about this. The arguments are so-and-so,
and I think we should reverse or affirm so that there is some conversation and
then, okay, because again, this is standard.
The chief justice called for a vote. This is the part we care about.
He presumably asked his colleagues, okay,
who here thinks that citizens United has a case?
Now we know that the four liberal justices, Stephen's skins were briar suitor.
We're like, no, they do not have a case.
All that citizens United is doing is making a campaign ad.
This is electioneering. They're pretending it's a doc, but really it's not.
They should be regulated. On the other side,
we know that the four conservatives, Scalia, Thomas Alito, Roberts,
we're like, yeah, they got a case.
Citizens United's First Amendment rights are being pinched and so you had a
split like you often do on this court for Liberals, for conservatives,
but there are nine justices, so as always, all attention turned
to the man in the middle. Justice Anthony County,
so justice Kennedy is 80 he's been on the court for almost 30 years.
He is often the swing vote, making his opinion critical.
He is considered the court's pivotal swing vote in accord that's basically split
down the middle for four. Kennedy is the ultimate swing vote,
the one ring to rule them all.
[inaudible]
all right, let's just talk about Justice Kennedy for a second.
He has been the swing vote on this course so many times that he's often called
the most powerful person in America and most powerful man in the country and by
many stretches because very often his vote is the only vote that matters.
You could argue that this one dude has determined more about your life as an
American than almost any other single guy,
but from the outside, for people who don't really know much about the court,
I e me, you know, maybe not you but me.
It can be really hard to predict what he is going to do on any given case,
which way he's going to.
For example, on a big voting rights case, he sides with the conservatives,
the Marshall Plan was very good to the Morale Act of no northwest ordinance but
but on eminent domain, he sides with the liberals, hey showing him,
it does say to be ronic than 100% goes to the developer and not to the property
owner. Now on gun rights, the Heller case,
if you talked about he swung conservative. Hey Pace.
I view it as a general right to bear arms, right?
Without reference to the militia either way. But on environmental protection,
he goes liberal greater the harm, the greater the risk class action.
He goes conservative under this, not clear to me what,
what is the unlawful policy? Gay Marriage. He goes, liberal,
same sex couples may exercise the fundamental right to marry all states, no
longer made this liberty be denied to them.
Does this winger, this swing the nose going?
I wanted the actions. So,
and when the chief justice went around the room and got to Kennedy and was like,
all right, Kennedy, what's it going to be this time from the outside?
It was anyone's guess. But as I mentioned,
one of the sort of cool things about the citizens United case is it gives you a
little window into the mind of this very powerful,
very mysterious man. So before he answers, let's go into his mind.
Okay.
I was born in Romania, Bucharest, Romania.
In the days of communism.
You may wonder why is there an eastern European man in the brain of justice,
Anthony Kennedy. That'll make sense. In just a minute. Bear with me for now.
All you need to know is that this is Alex Kazinski.
He's an influential judge who sits in the ninth circuit in California.
Yeah. My father was, um, was actually a party member. Uh, he was, uh,
a member of the party before the war. This is world war two.
He totally believed in communism and so there was a great system and uh, uh,
reviewed that.
But Alex remembers a moment when he was at his dad's office,
I guess I was about seven years old or seven or eight or something. And um,
my father wasn't there,
but a couple of other comedies officials were, and as they're standing there,
Alex picks up a newspaper, starts reading it,
newspaper called Free Romania. And so I live at free Romania.
And then I sort of, I have sent to be funny, I guess I said, well,
I don't know why they call it free Romania because as so many people in person,
you just thought he was making a joke.
But apparently this got my father into very serious trouble.
The officials essentially threatened his dad because of this joke question was
whether the, they were teaching me disloyal things at home.
Eventually they cleared them, but it was a, it was touching girl. So after that,
my father had this a signal. He says,
if you're ever in public with me and you say something and you hear me pinching
my nose and sniffing, uh, you just stop talking, whatever it is you're saying.
Usually you don't give an explanation. You don't continue to just stop talking.
Years later, Alice Kazinski would leave Romania, leave communism behind,
come to California, become a lawyer, then a clerk.
Okay. Clerk in a Sacramento for Anthony Kennedy,
who was then a new judge on the ninth circuit.
He says, he told Anthony Kennedy this story. Oh yes.
And they talked a lot about what it's like to live in a place where you can't
speak your mind. Oh, sure. Oh, sure. Of course.
Now who knows what exact effect has had on Anthony Kennedy's mind,
but we know that that story is in there. My honor,
I will do my best mixed in with all the cub scouts,
both service youth and the sights and smells of Sacramento, California,
where he grew up,
of course mixed in with all the Catholic church services and
stuff from, you know, summer spent, an Austria teaching.
But we know that story was in there.
And the reason why I pointed out was that we also know that at a certain point
growing up, Anthony Kennedy read a book that really lodged in his head.
1984 one of the most important works ever written.
1984 of course, is the dystopian novel by George Orwell.
Kennedy talks about it all the time and speeches in 1984. Um,
the dictatorship was always surveilling you, trying to control your thoughts.
You thought
in 1984 has one of the most brilliant scenes in literature.
The protagonist is being tortured.
Do you remember writing in your diary?
Freedom is the freedom to say two plus two equals four.
They want him to say the two and two is five.
Okay.
If finally you can't stay on the torture anymore. I don't think you like it,
please. Okay, two and two is five
but the torture continues.
Okay,
why are you continuing to use it?
The torture continues not until you just say it, but until you believe it.
I was good, which to wish swayed me did.
You can see fine Red Sea better.
This is a powerful reminder that governments want to plan your destiny.
They want to plan what you think and this must never happen.
[inaudible]
so clearly
inside Anthony Kennedy's mind,
and maybe this is as close to an ideology as he has,
he's often talked about as having very little discernible ideology.
Well maybe this is it inside his mind. There is a fear,
a primal fear of the government getting too close of it reaching its
authoritarian tentacles into our lives. In our minds,
in our bodies.
The framers add idea,
which is central to western thought.
This is how we put it at his supreme court confirmation hearing in 1987 and that
is that there is a zone of liberty as on a protection,
a line that's drawn where the individual can tell the government beyond this
line, you may not go
itself.
To go back to the secret room
when Chief Justice Roberts asked Justice Kennedy, all right, Kennedy,
which way you're going to swing. I imagine what he said,
emphasis on the word imagine is, all right, MR chief,
I know you think I'm a swinger. I know everybody else thinks I'm a swinger,
but on this issue, I do not swing.
Not only do I think that citizens United
has a case,
but I think that campaign finance law that would limit their speech should
government
United States stood in front of our court and said that it was lawful to ban a
book that, that, that, that can, that can't be lie.
No.
We knew that two things happened after Kennedy sort of gave his answer and said,
let's go big. Let's tear it down.
We know that the Conservatives on the court were like, oh,
I like where you're going with this, and they started to gravitate to his side.
We also knew the David Souter. He was the justice in court.
Ah, she lie about anything. She's deceitful. She's ruthless, cunning, dishonest.
I mean, this sounds to me like campaign advocacy,
who is basically accusing citizens United of trying to pretend they weren't
playing politics when really they were,
we know that justice Souter got really pissed because if we go into David's
suitors bind his room within a room,
the view is very different.
David Souter is a new Englander. He's quiet.
Bookish spends long afternoons reading,
walking through the silent hemlock forest.
This is a story that suitors home in New Hampshire was stack with so many books
that his house actually needed a new foundation,
which is to say his reaction here was very out of character. By all accounts,
he was not happy because Kennedy's whole thing that liberty is the law.
Nothing should compromise that that for suiter set off alarm bells
because I exercise my liberty to the greatest possible extent.
I can suppress the rights of a lot of people.
That is suitor giving a talk in 2012 and what he means is that liberty and
equality have to be imbalanced.
Both can't win all the way all the time,
and if corporate money just starts pouring into elections,
that's basically handing a megaphone to the richest people in society.
There's got to be the possibility of a limitation on corporations so that they
do not drown out other species.
No, we don't really know what David Tudor was thinking in this moment,
but I imagined them thinking forward to everything that was about to happen.
An explosion and political campaign donation. The Koch brothers,
the Koch brothers,
these two brothers are trying to buy American or billionaires are backing
Hillary Clinton over Donald Trump, essentially super packs.
They're allowed to give unlimited funds.
Hillary Clinton gaining support from the wealthy,
secretive billionaire hedge fund tycoon is credited by many with playing an
instrumental role in Donald Trump's election.
Whatever he was actually thinking that moment.
We know that after Kennedy made his stance, said, let's go bake justice.
Souter Justice Souter wrote a very, very
strong draft,
a real bridge burning descent. It's explosive. Marsha Coyle, Jeff Toobin,
Jeffrey Rosen of the national constitution center.
He said that Kennedy's opinion is really an illegitimate use of the court's
power. Yeah.
The way the court was proceeding with wrong
suitor accuses the court of judicial activism,
overreaching of taking a narrow case,
a teeny little case about one teeny little film and then using it illegitimately
as a hobby horse to really rewrite the laws of campaign finance regulation.
He argued that this kind of move essentially makes them,
the court look like a bunch of political hacks.
It's questioning the integrity of the court itself.
No,
unfortunately we can't read that descent that pseudo wrote because his papers
won't be public until 50 years after his death.
All we know is that he most certainly sent a draft around to the other eight
justices and then what I've been told is just Souter went to chief justice route
births and said, basically, look, you know,
if we do this now, we will look bad.
Your court, the Roberts court will look bad.
Someone described his argument as a,
there are a few institutional hot buttons that you press and the court stops and
thinks, and just as suitor was pressing one of those hot buttons,
apparently saying to a chief justice that your cord is going to look bad is like
the supreme court equivalent of going nuclear. In the meantime,
while all this is happening, you've got the three B's, bows, Busey, Bob,
a Bose [inaudible], Bose Vasia,
[inaudible] bows,
just dying for an outcome. And apparently every day
we would go down to the court to see 'em if they were gonna issue the decision
in our case that day. And of course, each day, no decision,
no decision, no decision.
Yeah. And it's now the end of June.
So now we're down to the last day of the court,
10:00 AM June 29th.
We're back in the court, uh, before, uh, the justices come on the bench,
the clerk of the court walks into the courtroom and, uh,
goes up to Ted Olson. He is, if you recall the lawyer for the BS and says,
I'm going to have to talk to you. Uh, something later.
Something unusual is going to happen. And Ted Olsen, uh, he told me later,
his first thought was, oh, did I do something wrong?
The Marshall Calls order
the honorable,
the chief justice and the associate justices at the Supreme Court of the United
States. Oh, Yay. Oh, Yay. Oh, Yay.
The chief opens the session. And then in 1964,
Congress enacted the Civil Rights Act.
Kennedy reads an opinion in a different case and then RBG
reads a descent, but they had no vested right to promotion in a different case.
And then Scalia gets up there, the bark of state law remains,
but his bite is not with an opinion in a different case,
this is a strange result. But finally,
Chief Justice Roberts comes back in.
And so the very last thing the chief justice says before he, you know,
ends the term [inaudible] case number Oh eight two oh five citizens United
versus the Federal Election Commission. Yes,
there will be re argument in citizens United is set for re argument later this
term. Boom. Chief Justice Roberts basically says,
we're not going to make up our mind today.
We're going to come back and talk about this again and we're going to debate it
on Kennedy's terms is the campaign finance law McCain-Feingold
[inaudible]
an infringement of free speech.
Okay.
And then after he says that this is what happens next.
Now we note with sadness that this is the last session in which our friend and
colleague Justice David Souter will be on the bench with us. Sooner
is out.
We wish him the best in his well deserved retirement.
On this occasion we have sent justice Souter a letter that I will now read
stated today. Dear David,
we have all felt a profound sense of loss since the announcement of your
decision to retire. Eventually he quotes the New England poet Robert Frost.
You understand your desire to trade white marble for white mountains and return
to your land of easy wind and downy flight.
Oh, you will not be among us in our daily labors after he finishes
just a or stern.
I've written the following reply. Dear colleague
[inaudible]
you are generous.
Letter is touched me more than I can say and I will only try to leave you with
some sense of what our common services meant tonight.
He also quotes Robert Frost.
You quoted the poet and I will to in words that set out the ideal of the life
engaged we love and need are one
that phrase accounts for the finest moments of my life on this court.
As we have agreed or continued with each other over those things that matter to
decent people in a civil society. For 19 terms,
I have lived that life with you.
All of us sharing our own best years with one another working side by side his
fellow servants and his friends.
I will not sit with you at our bench again after the court rises for the sum of
this time, but neither will I retire from our friendship,
which has held us together despite the pool of the most passionate dissent.
It just made the work lightest through all my tenure here and for as long as I
live,
I will be thankful for it and be under a very grateful obligation to each one of
you.
You as affectionate like David
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
all right, let's be real.
I mean we cannot say for certain why justice Souter retired at that moment.
Justice Souter had said for a long time that he didn't like DC,
that he wanted to have time to hike while he was still vigorous enough to do it.
We also will probably never know exactly why Robert's held the case over for re
argument.
What we do know is in holding the case over that mint suitors inflammatory
bridge burning dissent would never be published.
The Roberts court got to save face and not have this kind of internal fight,
um,
dirty laundry aired and basically avoided the embarrassment that would've come
from the publication of this explosive descent. Okay.
Fast forward a couple of months.
The court reconvenes one more time to hear the case. The room is packed.
Standing Room.
Well here we argument this morning in case zero eight two oh five citizens
United versus the federal election committed commission.
And here's the thing, everybody knew it was going to happen.
I think.
So you're asking us to have an ongoing chill against speech and there's no place
where an unknowing show was more dangerous than in the elections context.
The government silences a corporate objective and those corporations may have
the most knowledge of this.
Underside preparations have lots of knowledge about environment,
transportation issues and your silings in them. During the election.
It'll probably come as no surprise that Kennedy did a whole lot of talking,
a whole lot of carrying on and when the court finally decided the case,
we had the landmark decision five to four decision
in case zero eight two oh five citizens United vs the FEC.
Justice Kennedy has the opinion of the court,
but if the first amendment has any force,
it prohibits congress from finding or Jaylene citizens or associations of
citizens for simply engaging in political speech.
Political speech is indispensable to decision making in a democracy,
and this is no less true because the speech comes from a corporation rather than
an individual and the government seeks to use its full power,
including the criminal law to command where a person may get his or her
information or what does trust is tours he or she may not hear.
It uses censorship to control thought this is unlawful.
The First Amendment confirms the freedom to think for ourselves.
Gosh, no.
Obviously a lot of people were not happy about this decision.
I arrived on behalf of the vast majority of the American people.
You had the kind Newkirk's of the world sneaking in cameras and the court.
You had President Obama at a state of the union last week.
The Supreme Court reversed a century of law that I believe will open
the flood gates for special interests
including foreign corporations.
Basically calling out the justices who were right there in the audience and
without limit in our lucky and they were sitting right in front of them there.
At one point the camera zooms in on Justice Alito just as a Lito appears date at
least crane. He sees remodelings done. [inaudible] Justice Samuel Alito,
the grimace thing and mouthing the words. Not True.
Speaking of true, here's what's true. The upshot of this decision,
I think most people would agree is that sooner was right, Obama was right.
Suddenly you had a ton more money in politics.
Citizens United has made it possible to raise inordinate amounts of money.
The exact amount of new money that flooded in is a little bit hard to measure,
but what's pretty clear is that all those super packs,
super past super pack is super pack that you hear about. You know,
I've been talking about super packed for almost a year now.
He does things where like an individual can give unlimited amounts of money to
get someone elected or not.
Now what we've got are kind of rogue billionaires putting money into secret
group.
It's safe to say that the citizens United decision basically threw gasoline on
that fire, but before we get ahead of ourselves,
it's not to say that everybody hates this decision. Not ever,
but I think people who object to it, uh, I've gone off the deep end.
I think they've lost their minds. I think they're not totally liberals.
This is ninth circuit judge Alex Coz Zinsky again, he was the guy in
Kennedy's head.
The case stands for the simple proposition that when you band together with
other people, you don't lose your freedom of speech,
whether they be a union or association corporation.
You know a lot of, a lot of organizations take the corporate form.
This is Michael Door. Oh my friends call me Mike.
But professionally I more often go by Michael.
He's a professor of law at Cornell, a former Kennedy clerk,
and even though he is critical of the decision,
he says you do need to keep in mind that any opinion itself,
Justice Kennedy points out that under the law as it was written,
the ACL EU would be forbidden from putting on its website an essay promoting the
candidacy of a pro free speech candidate.
The NAACP couldn't promote a pro civil rights candidate to which you might
argue, well those groups are not for profits.
There should be a difference between not for profits and for profits lot.
The Washington Post is a for profit. CNN is a for profit.
These are core institutions of our democracy.
They're protected not only by freedom of speech, by freedom of the press.
So you say, well, okay,
so we're going to make an exception for media corporations. Well,
what's a media corporation?
Media corporations are often just divisions of other gigantic corporations.
For a while, uh, NBC was a division of General Electric.
Does that mean that you're going to carve up which parts of their funds can go
to the speech rather than to other parts?
And do we really want to trust the government to draw the lines? In other words,
things can get really complicated fast, which is why Ellis Kaczynski says
freedom of speech is freedom of speech.
Like just don't touch it, keep the government away from it. And he says,
when this citizens United decision came out
seemed perfectly right to me. Still seems absolutely correct.
And I think everybody who, uh, all the people who object to it being foolish.
Now, justice Kennedy for his part about two years ago, uh,
he was at Harvard law school. Okay.
There's one over here and having what they call these public conversations with
the Dean when a student, uh, I'm David, I'm a oneL as well.
Thank you for coming to speak to us. Got Up and asked him,
do you regret your decision? Uh, five years later.
I'm curious if you can stand by some of the assumptions that underlied your
opinion there when you see all the money that has poured out of Trump to our
election system. And he said, no, no,
I don't regret the decision.
Certainly in my own view. Um,
what happens with money in politics is, is not good,
but it does seem to me one of the things is the disclosure.
People don't really have to worry because we have disclosure laws. You know,
when these corporate contributions are being made,
they have to reveal who they are and who their funding sources are.
This is something he actually talked about explicitly in his citizens United
decision.
The act has provisions for extensive disclosure and he told the students that
transparency will protect you. It will protect us.
You'll live in this cyber age.
You don't need to wait for three months after the election for a report on who
gave the money. It can be done in 24 hours.
The voters don't like the people who are funding. You don't vote for him.
His point is that if you have the information you need to make a good decision,
nobody's free speech should be limited at all,
and this is frankly a perfect example of the kind of high minded principle that
works in reality. Not at all.
No.
I mean he's right. There are disclosure laws, but they're really,
really easy to get around. For example,
right now I could write a $3 million check to a five oh one C for like citizens
United or the NAACP for that matter, and they would never have to tell anyone
that that money came from me. I could just hide in the shadows.
That's why these kind of donations are often called dark money that owe money.
Now there are people who could change this who can make disclosure and actual
meaningful thing. For example,
[inaudible]
[inaudible],
the FTC is one of those places
[inaudible]
the FEC could choose to fix all the loopholes and require that all the money
that is coming to politics in the wake of citizens United,
at the very least be identified, be sourced. The problem is,
is that the FTC is by law to have no more than three commissioners be a member
of the same party at once.
So essentially they want there to be balanced between Democrats,
Republicans and independents. And in this day and age,
what that means is gridlock.
And so the idea of strengthening disclosure laws comes up,
gets stalled, comes up, get stalled, comes up, get stalled, comes up,
get stalled.
Couple years ago. Here's a little fun bit of tape. A couple of years ago,
two of the Democratic members on the commission guts so frustrated at the
non-action of this commission that they petition their own commission to allow
for public debate about things like strengthening disclosure.
This is the recording of the open meeting of the Federal Election Commission
held on June 18th, 2015 what happened? The petition before us today,
this is commissioner and Ravel is solely to allow people to comment directly to
the commission about issues that are of great importance to everyone in this
country. And rebel is a democrat. She and her colleague Commissioner One, Trump.
Ellen Weintraub.
Thank you chair Rambo brought the petition and as soon as they finished making
their opening statements, Mr Vice Chair. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you Madam Chair. One of the
Republican members of the commission and got by the name of Matthew Peterson
said, okay, so you want to bring a petition, but you know, look,
I'm looking in the rules here and it says that only a quote person can bring a
petition
and our definition of person excludes or says does not include the federal
government or any authority of the federal government.
That would seem to indicate that a commissioner acting in his or her official
capacity does not qualify as a person under FTC rules. I mean, first of all,
let me say, I,
I cannot believe that you are actually going to take the position that I am not
a person. I just, I find that a corporation is a person,
but I'm not a person, but we're not in the realm of common sense.
We're in the realm of 11th CFR and I will stipulate that we're not in the realm
of common sense when we were dealing with this book. But it does what it says.
You actually want to insist that I'm not a person. That's right.
That's another FTC, Commissioner Carolina Hunter, Republican. That's right.
That's so bad. It's gotten,
my colleagues will not admit that I'm a person that's really striking because
I'm a member of this commission.
I am not a person is just kind of dumbfounded. I didn't mean literally,
you're not a person. Of course you're person are going to be really does. No,
I think, I think you're not an alien, at least not today. But, um, but uh,
you, I asked the vice chairman yesterday, I said,
are you guys going to have a problem with this? Is it alright?
Could I just finish my, I didn't say anything. I was just going like this.
If you don't, if that bothered you, I'll put my hand down.
I'll call on you next. Thank you.
Can I really do find it comical that you're going to a,
you are so opposed to having,
giving the public this opportunity to weigh in on these issues that you're
willing to take the legal position that were not persons.
I find it comical that um, we got an email from some kids. Something to add.
Well, um, several things. I mean a, you know,
it's, it's ironic, there's a lot of irony on the agenda today,
but as I said, I'm happy to consider new proposals for changes in procedures.
I just don't like to do it on an ad hoc basis. Like the petition.
This meeting is adjourned.
And Ravel, uh, one of the two Democrats you just heard who brought the petition,
resigned from the FEC in 2017 she left out of frustration.
And if the FTC is kind of useless when it comes to fixing this whole money and
politics thing, and if the courts have said with the courts, have said, well,
where do we look for hope? The IRS Congress,
I mean, they must be more functional, right, right.
[inaudible] [inaudible] documentary justice Kennedy Documentary,
Justice Kennedy documentary, technical engineering.
That can't be right. Justice Kennedy, Justice Kennedy,
Justice Kennedy Election Justice Kennedy
more perfect is produced by me jet boom Rod Susie Lectin Berg, Jenny Lawton,
Kelly prime, Sean Ramas from Alex Overington, Julia Longoria and Sarra.
Cari Sean, you go with Ellie ms style, Christian Pfarius, Linda Hirshman,
David Gable and Michelle Harris.
This episode was produced with Kelsey Pageant Supreme Court audio is from
Ogaden,
a free law project in collaboration with the legal information institute at
Cornell.
Leadership support for more perfect is provided by the Joyce Foundation.
Additional funding is provided by the Charles Evans Hughes Memorial Foundation.